so my question is in regards to mainline
Protestant is in here in the state since
the four factors you have laid out
arguably you know the Episcopal Church
for instance meets and I'm has met a
number of those factors and increasingly
so as its declined so how do you got a
very simple answer for this demography
there's a wide wide widely shared
misunderstanding which is systematically
propagated by by certain religious
movements within the United States
evangelicals that the growth of
evangelicalism has to do with the
relative to mainland process of them has
to do with the success of their their
outreach or the character of their
theology basically is all about average
levels of P male fertility evangelical
group have you know on it evangelical
women for example on average have you
know 3.4 3.5 children during their
lifetimes whereas mainline protestants
you know are well below replacement
levels 1.4 and more liberal Protestant
congregations obviously you know to the
degree to which religious reproduction
is partly about biological reproduction
is about that to a large degree people
switch but not as much as you might
think over their lifetimes they
typically switch within within
denominational families the decline of
mainline protestants and that's almost
all about declining levels of a female
fertility now that rate that point you
to what the real theological question is
which is you know what is what it why do
you even Jellico's have more kids and i
don't have a you know i don't have a
great answer to that question but if you
know if you come up with one you know i
guarantee you'll get a lot of attention
how about episcopalian how are the
biscuit aliens having this gaping hole
most i am one but we've got a gaping
hole between 12 and 35 in our
congregations so so it's not just the
low rates of fertility it's a it's a
lower rates of attraction of those who
you give birth to right so so which is
which is which is
a sense of kind of issue of internal
transmission and ability to internally
transmit also also varied using that
place at all you know I you know I
haven't really looked at the numbers
really closely reason I mean one thing I
can say is that you know what you're
describing is a fairly typical
phenomenon you know that you know in mid
to late adolescence people leave when
they get married and then when they have
kids they tend to return so I mean
that's a that's a very common to the
very common thing what might be true is
that you know that that the the kind of
stricter churches you know evangelical
or Pentecostal church the stricter
churches which really have much stronger
form you know in for theological reasons
have apply much stronger forms of
collective pressure and individuals to
remain within the fold may actually do a
better job that's less I don't know the
numbers whether they do a better job
actually keeping people active between
you know the ages of you know whatever
15 or 18 and 35 or 40 it may may well be
that they do but you know whether that
matters or not a lot in the long run
again at the that's another question
maybe it does maybe it does in the sense
that it could be that's part of the
answer to the fertility problem that
those are that that's precisely the
period of La to adolescence and young
adulthood when people develop certain
kinds of long-standing attitudes towards
sexuality marriage reproduction and so
on but that's just a that's just a
thought I don't know if it's true can i
push back just a little bit on the idea
of fertility answering it all because
it's my understanding that the kind of
cradle Protestantism is fading also that
that's sort of a corresponding trend
that work so it seems to me like there
has to be something else accounting for
it given that they are meeting a number
of these factors or is it anticipating
something that might then now affect
some of these flourishing growing
religions that they haven't yet faced
and with
it's conceivable but you know again I
think that you know I there have been
several studies of this one in
particular quite recently within the
last three or four years that you know
really find that almost do this
extraordinary amount of this or
variation it is just explained by pure
demography and i can give you the site
afterward now you know whether or not
that that's changing i mean somebody you
know you'd have to really sort of go and
look at the data to figure out whether
that's the case it's not implausible
mean what you're saying it's just you
know the questions whether it's true